you go and register I'll hope you
upstairs with the bags no that's okay I
can get it from here I'm supposed to
take the room okay welcome sir i'm
alright just your signature please all
right
mr. shravan hopes the room will be to
your satisfaction ah yes and the view is
second to none Wow
Oh
No
to them you know you stole mrs. an
office job you gotta pick somebody to
trust Jack now sit down
you
you brought your dog QP dog cause I
personal when I was at my house for a
walk
it's better there shaking afterwards
than during first person I ever killed
Jack was innocent what do you do she
she didn't do anything she was a
bystander somebody who just just came up
behind me to quit
how do you get over something like that
you're lucky you get past it it's not
the same thing you're not just an
analyst anymore your operation now Tokyo
London the United States it's gonna be a
wipeout you Americans like to think of
yourselves as direct perhaps you are
just the rude perhaps just touching
Jack you got another problem you lied to
me for three years how many more of
course not are you I can we have a
minute please no this is geopolitics
mount couples therapy